so you can't do this you got to work
magic outside i remember one time
i hooked up with this girl on a friday
night i'm going to figure this out
[__] i was
i was sexually [__] like nothing i
think we swapped spit it was freezing
out
and she let me suck a tits behind the
fire department
and i went home then i had all these
illusions that were going to have sex
outside the next day
so the next day it snowed like two feet
of snow and i went up there like at
eight in the morning and built like a
sexy glue
you should have seen me out there with
artificial turf and [__]
[Laughter]
it's [__] up getting [__] up in a
sexy glowy [__]
but i've never been like i talk a big
game up here on stage like if
if i get off state and the chick shows
me a tit i'll [__] have an anxiety
attack
i'm one of those guys i'll just pass up
like i was anti-all like i was a
catholic catholic like
growing up i was in catholic school like
from the first grade on to like the
sixth grade
and they put the fear of god in me and
then you know god else what else
[__] put the fear of god in me but i
never and i didn't have sex till i was
19. i didn't get a blow job until i was
like 21. that was like my last walking
to the valley of debt
like when i was a kid if somebody said
that girl gave head i'd avoided her like
the [__] play
that's the devil's daughter
when i was a sophomore in high school
this girl called marathon woman that's
the name they gave her
she sucked 16 dicks after a football
game let me tell you something
you know me though i got felonies i'm
not a crime stop i almost call the cops
on that [__]
16 dicks in one afternoon people live to
be 80 don't suck 16 dicks
and i knew nothing about nothing but 16
dicks
i see her in high school and run the
other [__] way i'm like
she's got something
it's true man i was never crazy as a
young guy like that i had friends that
did all
the craziest thing i did the craziest
[__] thing i did
you know my mom was crazy like my cuban
she was old school cuban
and when i was growing up actually my
mom was single for a long time and she
would always look me in the eye at
breakfast and go when you get older
you gotta eat [__]
and i go what are you talking about and
she said in spanish when you get older
eat papaya
and i said i don't like papaya i like
bananas no [__] bananas in this
[__] house
there's a papaya [__] house only
so i didn't know what the [__] she was
talking about all those years like
eating [__] i didn't
i never dreamt of that [__] that shit's
disgusting i didn't know
when i was about 12 i went to my aunts
and i sniffed the bras one day
just to see what it was like it smelled
like nothing i was like that's okay but
i can't imagine
[__] doing that stuff but then when i
was like 16 i was like i gotta eat
somebody's [__] i gotta do this
i really do i think it's somebody i'm
like i'm ready to suck somebody's [__]
you know
my mom had been dead for like a year to
honor her i'm like i gotta suck
somebody's [__]
it's time she's been in the ground for a
year it's time